on va continuer la discussion avec les
chars paradis qui est expert en
télécommunications
bonsoir bonsoir quelle est l'importance
de la décision du crtc aujourd'hui
monsieur le rat dit c'est vraiment une
décision importante pour les
consommateurs ça fait très longtemps que
les consommateurs se plaignant qu'ils
paient trop cher d'ailleurs ou canal
dont on perd encore trop cher pour notre
service de téléphonie mobile mais au
moins brèves deux ou trois ans d'études
certes et c'est finalement décidé de
donner de l'avant avec des changements
assez important qui devrait sur le coût
moyen terme baisser les coûts pour les
consommateurs
puis d'ailleurs j'inviterai les
consommateurs si la fin juillet prochain
d'aller voir sur les sites web des
compagnies de téléphonie mobile parce
qu'il doit effectivement et au prix
qu'elles pourront avoir des forfaits
très intéressant pour les consommateurs
donc c'est un c'est une décision qui
apportera des changements réels
tangibles pour les gens oui tout à fait
puis d'ailleurs ça va vraiment donner
l'occasion de voir clair dans le sens
que est ce qu'on est capable d'avoir
vraiment de concurrence au canada
donc vous avez ici un début de
discussions les trois grands joueurs au
canada dont plus de 90,3 % du marché
alors ils peuvent pas en avoir moins de
vraiment tout leur céder le marché et y
ont déjà une place prépondérante
et puis le service aujourd'hui 10 mais
c'est assez durs et maintenant vous
allez rendre vos réseaux disponibles
pour toutes les autres fournisseurs qui
veulent rentrer sur le marché et on voit
aussi s'attendre à ce que il offre aux
consommateurs des tarifs qui devraient
éventuellement permettre à tout le monde
de choisir le forfait créé son affaire
et puis d'après ce qu'on peut voir dans
la décision d'aujourd'hui
effectivement il ya des choix qui vont
être là 15 dollars par mois 35 $ par
mois 100 $ par année pour un forfait
téléphonique qui pourrait vous
satisfaire
c'est quelque chose qu'on n'a jamais vus
et puis ça fait très longtemps que les
gens
comment ça va fonctionner quand on dit
que cogeco xplornet tout vidéotron qui
sont des fournisseurs dits régionaux
pourront avoir accès au réseau de bell
telus et rogers ça va marcher comment ça
et ça va prendre combien de temps mais
si on regarde par exemple qu'en ce
moment il ya des ententes antérieures
ces belles les pays partagent par
exemple les tours entend cependant la
voiture on voit qu'il est ou qui sont un
but partout manger un vrai territoire
et puis les entreprises se font une
entente et puis il sait ça nous permet
de réduire nos frais de port offert deux
tournants faire une haie de s'en servir
ce que ça va permettre aujourd'hui ça va
obliger les gros joueurs de partager
leurs infrastructures avec les
opérateurs dans les régions qui
devraient favoriser la croissance de
plus de joueurs dans le marché et
éventuellement une baisse de tarif
même si par exemple en 2018 et 2019 à
une baisse de 13% en moyenne du coût de
la téléphonie mobile pour les canadiens
il reste que même aujourd'hui on est
encore on perd beaucoup plus cher que
par exemple en france on paie presque
sept fois plus cher que les français en
france pour leurs services mobiles
annonce qu'elle épouse et sa part
atteint que saab et telus et rogers va
faire en sorte que ça va que ça pourrait
nuire à la aux investissements de ces
entreprises là dans notre infrastructure
non je crois que ils sont très bien
placés pour avoir pour nenê ont leur
part de marché même s'ils favorisent des
nouveaux joueurs il reste qu'ils sont
omniprésents dans le quotidien du monde
à tous les jours on entend parler de
bell rogers telus continuellement ses
des grosses entreprises qui ont déjà une
grosse part de marché à se reprendre
changer cette situation récemment rogers
a proposé d'acheter chat dans l'ouest
canadien
est ce que la décision d'aujourd'hui
change quelque chose pour cette
transaction non attends
action va pouvoir aller de l'avant parce
que ce que ça va permettre finalement
c'est croire qu'ils vont avoir plus de
moyens dans certaines provinces de
l'ouest où le site est plus difficile
j'en avais pris une grande place dans le
marché de l'ouest
alors maintenant on va se retrouver avec
trois gros joueurs ils vont toucher à
peu près égale à travers le territoire
du canada parfait on va effectivement
suivre votre conseil on va surveiller
les forfaits d'ici cet été
jean paradis merci beaucoup pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez vous sur
la chaîne ici et redit